So last week, after I filmed myself cleaning my room,
I had a lot of questions and comments about my bed,
which is super high,
which my husband custom built so that we would have storage underneath,
because we only have about three feet
on either side of the bed in this room,
so we really don't have a lot of room for storage,
and we needed that. So we custom built this bed,
and as you can see, it's almost waist height on me.
And I'm pregnant,
so this is becoming increasingly harder to get into bed.
But I will show you how I get into bed for now,
and then my husband is going to build me a stool
for when I'm more heavily pregnant. I just put my knee up
and hoist myself in.